I'm 24. okay and I really really really
struggle with self-love
so
comes from parenting or environment
parents definitely that's okay that's
therapy that's surrounding yourself with
positivity you're in control of getting
yourself out by the way that's normal
right that's what everyone's dealing
with
dwelling on
any difference between you and most
people is you figured it out already
most people haven't even started the
Journey of understanding they don't love
themselves you're way ahead you have to
limit the time you interact with the
negative people in your life like if one
of your parents or both your parents are
negative you've got to speak to them
once a week not three times a day right
if your three best friends if one of
them is negative you've got to start to
cut that down you have to cut down
negativity and you have to pump in
positivity that's the only way that's
the work do you understand how lucky you
are that you know yeah do you yeah well
now I do definitely